він стріли в трата прати пісків їх і
цивільна річка і прагнули до вусів
тут не доводилося задонатити міситі
Україна витрачала контроль над частиною
території
ж dance 13 пунктів приписаних торик
втомився йти білорусі
у повному світі навички nano prep і на нього
вогнем киргиз обстрілявши заданим із пасти
лихачів значить дізнаєшся влади однак
період вино знають ішиби вище у мера
сніжок йому нову руку
вже починаю числу штаб ато сепаратисти
видно був його вогонь і ви до паростків бувають
оборони на ваш смак бровою
zarik лист у покращенні перемир'я
заданому він зоні ато заглянула пак і
Адже 200 людей ви до нього скинути
танк іменами ти танеш його школи бійня у
б дві сторони демонстративно ховала
комарами пішов або два до 1000в лідку
багато уроку
вчимо заданому врятувати лігачова bc30 адже
сотки в занедбаних подвоєний сторони за
вийшов і на старих позиціях
ефективний моніторинг з продумував
насті сепаратисти на відьому вигляд
українських ризикових напускати
міжнародних з пастир іллічів на все
ділянки підконтрольної їм території
представляти його б зараз то торкнутися
на блокпостах
їм занурюся збруєю засіки друковано
патус апарати стив на село комінтернове
врятувати лігачів кількою гнівом туди не
допускав і обійми плани нами в мене
повно нах за принципами у всіх на всіх
не вдалося а у темза різьбленими даними з
повна бойовиків за рік звір на ніч
близько трьох тисяч українців
ще 130 піскова служба active завищуються
заграта му так званих днр і лнр
повідомляєте в хату провалу не пункти
внесені виконаними завищують пункт пункті
у низьких у рік солідних встановлення
контролю над кордоном висновку не
іноземних мирського формувати до суду
на реформа не самі вибори за законом та
України